[whistles]
Hey.
(Forrest voice-over)
Being happy about everything
the universe brought my way
was clearly a bizarre way
to go through life.
Hey, Lucille,
look who found
some effective sunscreen
after all.
(Forrest voice-over)
And it was made all the more
complicated
by a surprise visit
from my ex-wife.
Oh, Suzanne.
Oh, wow.
Oh, great. Okay.
Could you
put the parasol down?
- I'd be happy to.
- I just want to sit and talk.
- Oh.
- The thing is, Forrest...
- Uh-huh.
- I've decided that what would
be best for me,
and for Eric--
would be best for
both of us,
- Mm-hmm.
- Is if we were to have...
a little break from you
and whatever effect that you
may be having on our lives.
(Forrest voice-over)
This was terrible news,
but given the parameters
of this review,
there was only one way
to react.
[chuckles]
- Yay. [laughs]
- Yay?
Well, yeah.
I think it's--
- I think that's great.
- You do?
I do.
I do, I do, I do, I do.
- [laughs]
- Oh, okay,
'cause I-I--
you know, I'm surprised.
I thought you were gonna,
like, literally freak out
and start,
like, throwing things
- and...
- [laughs]
No, I can see why
that's a good idea.
- Okay. Okay.
- Yeah.
Well, good, because I--
what I would like to do...
- Uh-huh?
- Is for you to waive
all of your visitation rights
and have no contact
with us at all.
Bye-bye, visitation rights.
- [chuckles]
- Are you okay?
- Yeah. Yup.
- What is this?
Are you on something,
or...
No, I'm not on anything,
I'm just--
What you're saying
- makes me happy.
- It does?
It does.
It really makes me happy.
To not see me and Eric
at all?
Um, how long were you
thinking for the break?
Well, I was thinking
something around two months.
For starters.
With no contact...
(Forrest voice-over)
If I weren't so very happy,
I might have begged her
to change her mind.
- Hooray.
- Hooray?
Yes. See, I think
two months is gonna go by
just like that!
[laughs]
(Forrest voice-over)
And the happy news kept coming.
(man) Are you Forrest MacNeil?
- Yes, I am.
Stand up and put
your hands behind your head.
You're under arrest
for homicide.
- Okay, uh...
- What's happening?
(Suzanne) Homicide?
- Stand up.
Put your hands
behind your head.
(Suzanne)
Forrest, what did you do?
Yay! It's great to hear
my rights.
You have the right
to remain silent...
There they go. I'm so glad
for the Constitution.
You have the right
to an attorney.
I'm so glad we
got rid of the king...
If you cannot afford
an attorney...
- So we have rights now.
- One will be provided for you.
(Suzanne)
Forrest, did you kill somebody?
I will see you
in two months, Suzanne!
Forrest!
(Forrest)
I get to take a ride
in a police car!